- Welcome everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the
Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Anti-Semitism.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series.
today's speaker, Pierre
Birnbaum is known to many of you
from his various visits
to Yale over the years,
the leading modern Jewish
historian in France,
Pierre Birnbaum is an emeritus professor
from the University of Paris 1,
where he taught political sociology.
While his early work focused
mainly on questions of
democracy and political elites.
His later work has studied modern,
earn an especially modern
French Jewish history
in a comparative perspective,
focusing especially on the way
that different paths of emancipation
involve different relationships
between Jews and the State.
An incredibly prolific scholar,
he's written over 20 books,
many of which have been
translated into English.
And some of them published
by Stanford University press.
I obviously can't list them all here,
but I'll cite just a few of
his titles to give you an idea
of the range of subjects he's worked on.
"The Jews of the Republic:
"A Political History
of State Jews in France
"from Gambetta to Vichy from 1996"
"Geography of Hope: Exile, the
Enlightenment Disassimilation
from 2008."
"The Anti-Semitic Moment:
A Tour of France in 1898"
which was published in 2011.
"A Tale of Ritual Murder in
the Age of Louis the 14th:
"Trial of Raphael Levy
1669" published in 2012.
And his, "Leon Blum: Prime
Minister, Socialist, Zionist"
was published in the Jewish live series
at Yale University Press in 2015.
His talk today is drawn from his new book,
which I have right here,
(speaking in a foreign language).
So translated would be,
"The Tears of History
"from Kishinev to Pittsburgh."
And it was published by Galimar this year.
So let me just say a word
about how things will work
and then we'll get going.
We can't see or hear the audience.
So, but we do wanna hear from
you in the Q and A function.
So please submit questions
at any time during the talk
in the Q and A section at
the bottom of your screen.
And I will ask them to
professor Pierre Birnbaum
after his talk, please
don't raise your hand
or say anything because
we can't hear or see you.
So I think that's about it.
And I will now turn it over to Pierre.
Please join me in
welcoming Pierre Birnbaum.
- It's a pleasure to
be able to speak to you
and to the audience at Yale.
And I'd like to thank you
from the bottom of my heart.
So let's jump to the core of the argument,
let's look to begin with at
the American exceptionalism,
since the beginning of
the American history,
no one could witness
any crusades, Pogroms,
violent mobilization against Jews.
Since the foundation of the United States,
no Jews were ever killed for being a Jew
at the result of anti-Semitic
violence until 1915,
during the famous Leo Frank Case,
more than 4,000 lynching
of African-American author,
mostly at the end of 19th century,
Native American were almost exterminated.
Sometimes Italian or
Irish were also killed
as a result of a Protestant
Catholic violence,
but Jews never face a strongly organized
anti-sematic mobilization until the 1930s.
Until recently, since
the constitution of 1787,
and it's article 16, six sections three,
abolishing any religious test
for joining the administration.
There were the kind of
separation of church and state
allowing Jews to enter
within the administration
and allowing them to become full citizens.
In reality, they remain far from the state
dominated by the wasp,
the Protestant elite.
They were safe in their environment,
but they joined mostly the professions
and joining a quiet life
in their local communities
in their suburbs.
They had no national power
and to use David Bial image,
they remains at the
periphery of the nation
safe far from the center, from
John Higam to a Isaiah Dyna,
most American historians,
outlined the marginal dimension
of anti-Semitism in the US
one could not find a crucial
central political event
linked to any anti-Semitic mobilization,
at least until the turn
of the 20th century.
Everyone remember Washington famous speech
to the Touro Synagogue,
"Jews should live in peace insecurity
"and threatened by no
one under the vine tree."
Using the Bible metaphor
that belongs to Mische four.
During those years,
there was a kind of cultural symbiose
between Jews and the American
who escaped from the English Pharaoh
and went through the Red
Sea IAS, Atlantic Ocean.
And we know that this vision
could be seen as naive
in some states, Jude could
not join the administration
until almost the end of the 19th century.
Those states remain in Christian.
We know that until the 20th century,
there were sometimes a
excluded from some hotels,
clubs, and seashore.
That a general grant took a
decision excluding the Jews
that there were unofficial
quarter in the Ivy League,
exogamic wedding, where often condemned
a kind of social antisemitism
was strongly felt by Jews.
You can find example in
the American literature,
look for instance, at Aaron James books,
at O'hara splendid book,
the meeting in Samara
in the context of 1930,
where at the very beginning of his novel,
a Christian woman said loudly,
"If a Jewish family is
going to set our streets,
"our children are going to
speak with a Jewish accent."
A book in which one find a
lot of antisemitic remarks
given by the inhabitants of the city.
Look at the recent book by Joshua Cohen,
"The Netanyahus" in the
context of the 60s, this time,
how strong, how the prejudices
against the only Jewish professor
appointed in an uptown university,
suddenly, he discover that he
is seen mainly as being a Jew
antisemitism in the US was
mostly social, not political
raising, no political violence
within the public's sphere.
The main idea of this
presentation is the following one,
the state being in my vocabulary,
weak decentralized as
Talk Ville once outlined,
Jews remain far from the
center, far from the state.
And we are almost never the target
of any political
antisemitism, like in France,
where on the contrary being
linked to a strong state,
they were seen as being
in charge of the state,
betraying the Catholic nation
and from the Dreyfus
affair to Vichy and so on,
they were facing a strong
political antisemitism,
nothing like that occurs in the US.
Therefore the lack
removed vision of history
seems to be foreign to
the American history.
The US is a perfect example
against this vision.
Implying the Jews always suffer
were killed, chases and torture.
In his famous article
published in Manara in 1928,
Salo Baron, soon to be appointed
as the first Jewish professor
at Columbia University.
Saw that Jews did not suffer
during the middle ages,
that it was a period of related freedom
compared to the painful
life of most peasants,
Jews could live a relative
protected collective
and cultural life in their ghetto.
Up to him, contrary to and his regrets,
and most Jewish historians,
the emancipation period,
celebrating the French revolution
reason and universal's values
could be seen as a period of suffering
different from the middle ages.
Later on, being the only historian
speaking at the Irishman trial,
Baron thought that modernity
not the middle ages
brought despair and deaths.
A time period when the state itself
was launching Pogroms and persecution.
Whether instead during the middle ages,
no king ever initiated
deliberately a Jewish persecution.
The Royal Alliance studied
later by Jose Yoroshami
protecting the Jews.
Even if this interpretation
was denied by Fritz Bear
and other historians,
if the king were often also active
during those antisemitic persecution,
if the cruises were
crucial murdering period
of Jewish history, it is
never less true that modernity
brought this persecution at a new level,
culminating with the Russian Pogroms
and above all with a shoa.
Therefore like most theory of history
seems to be an appropriated
vision of modernity.
If the Shoa gave a new legitimacy
to Lacromose vision of history,
Baron, now a full and celebrated
professor at Columbia.
Saw the United States
as the new middle ages,
a period during which
Jews in their community
were having a peaceful life
in a kind of liberal empire
and empire different from
the despotic Russian regime,
but never the less,
in which a deep collective
Jewish life could flourish.
The US, not old Europe should up to him
become the new center
of a lively Jewish life
fearing no persecution.
He created a new school of Jewish studies
focused on American Jewish life.
Now, at the core of Jewish history.
And he succeed contrary
to Joseph Yoroshami
who were still European
oriented, denying any values
the Jewish American history.
Baron born in Krakow and
having study at Vienna
became the new hero of the
United States pluralism
and decentralized society,
praising its exceptionalism
without considering
seriously various signs
of antisemitism even if
he published an article
on this dimension.
More or less, to contrast
between the US and the old Europe
seems therefore to be meaningful,
but Baron did not pay attention
to some crucial events
happening in the US.
And I think he never
mentioned the Leo Frank Case.
The Leo Frank Case is the first sign
that something is change.
The kind of turning point was happening
when the first Jew was
killed as a Jew in 1915.
Hanged and his body severally beaten
by some crowds of neighbors
of local notables.
It was suddenly like if Pogroms
were crossing the Atlantic
only several years after
the Kishinev Pogrom of 1903,
the massacre still extremely present
in the remembrance of American Jews
who recently immigrated to the US.
Kishinev in America,
its looked an oxymoron.
The murder of Leo Frank
could not be compared
to the Pogrom of Kishinev or of Kiev.
But nevertheless, this
unprecedented killing in America
was such a shock that it was seen
as some kind of Kishinev
violence occurring the US.
And Kishinev will never disappear
from the Jewish American consciousness.
It's still the reference.
The way the Lacromose
theory is felt in the US,
transmitted door to door, from
the generation to generation
of immigrant to another,
from the turn of the 20th
century up to nowadays,
this is a core of my
argument, when Leo Frank,
a Jew belonging to the upper
strat of Atlanta society
was accused of abusing and
killing the young Christian girl,
Mary Fagan, working in his factory.
The myth of ritual murder
had cross the Atlantic,
Christianism and
antisemitism and aintiJudaism
was for the first time emerging in the US.
In this city so open to
the Jews since centuries,
we all know the painful story
leading to Frank hanging
condemned to death by local juries,
surrounded by shouting antisemitic crowds.
This decision being confirmed
by the Supreme court of Georgia
and then by the Supreme
court of the United States,
without in fact, any serious
evidence against him,
he was never the less
pardon by governor Slayton,
who was seen immediately as quotation,
"The Kings of the Jew betraying Georgia."
Slayton being now himself,
surrounded by crowds trying to kill him.
(speaking in a foreign language)
The French antisemitic leader,
the journalist Watson
published violent article
against the Jews telling his readers,
the Jews are strengthening
the white Christian society
with their financial power.
Is literature with
exactly the same that you,
that once you could
find during, in France,
during the Dreyfus affair
or during the Vichy,
the Leon Blum period is violent,
is amazing in this newspaper of Atlanta,
I could give you references example,
but let's save some time.
During this short period
of violent antisemitism,
apparel can be seen
between Frank and Dreyfus
was prosecution occur
during the same period
for the first time French
national, antisemitism
and American local
antisemitism were quite close.
Both Dreyfus and Frank are innocent.
There was some strange similarity
during the prosecution,
like a similar dictation test.
Governor Slayton can be
compared to Captain Picard,
Jeseph Canarc to the
lawyer Louis Marshall,
Lucilla to Luci and so on.
But strong differences emerge,
the strong French State
was able to protect Dreyfus
from the crowds and finally in 1906,
Dreyfus was recognized as being innocent
by the (speaking in a foreign language).
The highest judicial court,
whether the local weak state of Georgia
was unable to protect Frank.
An armed gang of 150 local
notables, invade his jail,
took him and hang him.
And at the end of the story,
he was never recognized as being innocent.
He was pardoned but not
even sometimes nowadays
seen as innocent.
In 1983, a man confessed that Conley,
a black American working
in the factory told him
that he killed Mary Fagan.
Immediately the Ku Klux
Klan mobilized it's members,
at the end, a national
commission pardoned Frank.
Nowadays, the discussion still
goes exchange of argument.
No one's really know,
but what matters is a
memory of the Frank Case
within Jewish remembrance.
Even today, it's seen
at the local equivalent
of Russian Pogroms and
felt like the Frank Case
was also remembered for instance,
during the Pittsburgh Synagogue shooting,
I could give you example
where the reference
to Kishinev and to Leo Frank Case
are immediately brought during
the Pittsburgh shooting.
The next step bring bringing
the Lacrimose series
to the United States is the 1930.
When Roosevelt helped by some Jews
from Louis Brandais to Felix Frankfort,
From Henry Morgentaler to David Ligentaler
helped Roosevelt to build
a partial strong state,
able to face the deep economic crisis.
Frankfort was seen as a
Jew rolling Washington.
And the new deal became the Jew deal.
A wave of political
antisemitism spread in the US
that can be compared to the Dreyfus
or the contemporary Leon
Blum period in France,
during which thousands
of antisemitic militant
shout death to the Jews all over France.
Like in France for the
first time in the US,
a new political antisemitism
raise as an answer
to the close relation
between some Jews and the administration.
The white shirts, the khaki
shirt, the gray shirts
recruited thousands of
antisemitic militants
galvanized by father Kurdin speeches
or by William Pele of
Franklin Thompson Declaration
against the Jews in
Washington and Roosevelt
seen as a kosher president.
The direct influence of Nazism,
and Hitler Mein Kampf
was amazing in the US
and it will not disappear
in the further period.
Some years later on Jews were frightening
by the Loomberg presidential
antisemitic campaign
on which Philip wrote his marvelous novel,
if antisemitism did not disappear
during the second World War
seen by someone as a Jewish War.
One must remember that as soon as 1958,
bombs were sent to the Atlanta Synagogue
to Hebrew benevolent congregation
from Atlanta to Atlanta,
but everything was different.
This time, social
antisemitism, antiJudaism,
was now replaced by political antisemitism
spreading to the center
of the United States
in the main city of this nation.
It will never be stopped.
From Atlanta to Pittsburgh
through many important cities
from the East Coast to the West Coast,
the outright still
sharing Mein Kampf logic,
launched bombs against
many Jewish institution
and killed some Jews.
In 1977, Paul Franklin
influenced by Hitler
launched some bombs on
the Shalom Synagogue
and he said the following sentences,
"The only thing I regret,
"the only thing that Hitler didn't do,
"the only thing which is a pity,
"is that Hitler did not
really murder 6 million Jews.
"He should have killed all of them."
In 1978, William Pas,
published his famous,
"Turner Diaries", a book
which is more or less
forbidden even in the United States.
And eucrony influencing
a large number of members
of the Alt-right still shown openly
during the capital coup in Washington,
I could give you references by, forget it.
Time is running quickly.
In January 1981,
Allan Berg is killed by
members of the Arian Nation
in Denver in April, 1986,
Neil Rosenberg is killed
at the Al Torah institution
study at Pittsburgh already.
Obviously some violent antisemitic action
were a link to the nation of Islam
or to the Middle East evens,
but most of them are done
by members of the extremist.
Alt-right still influenced
by Hitler thought.
Between 1994 and 1999,
30 Jewish institution were
attack by member of the Alt-right
from San Luis to Los Angeles
or Pittsburgh or Chicago.
In 2000, members of the Folk Front,
shot Richard Baumhammers
at Pittsburgh again.
In 2005, a member of the Irian Nation
sent a bomb to the Oklahoma
Synagogue and so on and so on.
In January 2009, the election of Obama
gave a new strength to
the white extremist,
like Roosevelt Obama was seen by them
as a slave of the Jews,
an antisemitic propaganda
flow all over the country,
more than 7,000
antisemitic incidents occur
during the Obama presidency.
In April 2014, Glen Miller
Jr., shouting, "Hail Hitler."
Attack the Overland Park Jewish
community located in Kansas.
He was a member of the national
socially sporty of America.
And let's look at his declaration,
at to him Obama is a new road child.
The cabal is ruling
America, killing America,
the (speaking in a foreign language)
are running Wall Street
and so on and so forth.
Almost after Trump victory
on November 21, 2016,
neo Nazi almost the same day,
November 21 November 2016,
Neo Nazi gather at Washington and shout,
"Hi Hitler, hi Hitler, hi
Hitler, gaze the kicks."
Amazing, then August 2017 Charlesville,
the Ku Klux Klan, the Christ
in Identity, the Proud Boys,
the Vanguard America, the
Confederate White Knight,
the White Live Matters Partisans shouting,
"You will never replace us."
The slogan imaginated by the French
(speaking in a foreign language)
or shouting blood and soil, raising flags
on which figure (indistinct).
A turning point in American history.
The moment of extremist fury
leading directly to Pittsburgh,
killing in October 2018
at the Tree of Life Synagogue.
Robert Bowers, the killer
is a member of the White Supremacist.
11 members of the Synagogue were killed
much more than in France
at, during the same period.
Several others were several hurted.
Something unpredicted head
occur in the United States.
Thus, are we watching the end
of American exceptionalism,
the end of Salo Baron's dream.
Immediately Kishinev memory resurface,
the Kishinev Pogrom sung by Bialik.
His famous poetry has been transmitted
from one generation of Russian immigrants
to another generation till nowadays
most American Jewish
writers dealt with Kishinev
in their novels from
Abraham Caen to Philip Roth,
from Henry Roth to Saul
Billow, from Malamut
to Lameck Shapiro, Kishinev is mentioned
and describe by some crucial
characters of their novels.
After the Pittsburgh massacre,
let's quote what Matthew Friedman
an American historian said.
"We said Kurdish for the
dead people of Babi Yar
"of Kishinev, of Vlasborg, Mainz and York,
"and for so many awful things,
"which happened since 2000 years,
"but nowadays it's different.
"Kishinev it was in 1903,
Babi Yar it was in 1941.
"This time it's Pittsburgh in
the United States of America
"in the 21 century, we
thought it will never be back.
"It will never come back.
"It will never be like that again,
"it was a liar.
"We didn't know it and
so on and so forth."
So you do see how strong
the remembrance of Kishinev
is still during those very recent years
In the Pittsburgh massacre context,
Kishinev is mentioned
by many commentators,
by many journalists.
It was like if the Pogromist
had reached America
and then it never stops.
In April 2019, Timothy
Earnest influence again,
still by the Turner diaries.
Attacked the Poway
synagogue near San Diego,
killing a woman and hurting
the Rabbi and other members.
In November 2019, Richard autorist,
carrying Mein Kampf
again, always Mein Kampf,
at Mein Kampf in the
United States, amazing.
Attacks the Pueblo Synagogue,
telling the police quotation.
"I would've been happy if the holocast
"would've been an entire
reality, they must all die."
Then the story is known
and we are very close
to the conclusion of this talk.
After Biden victory on January
6, 2021, the capital coup,
initiated again by the
same antisemitic members
of the Alt-right, the
White Nazi Supremacist,
the Proud Boys, the Oathkeepers
showing openly the Turner diaries again,
and wearing t-shirts on
which it was written,
6 million was not enough.
Then is it the end of
American exceptionalism?
When Jews are becoming a central target
within the political
system, when like in France
or during the Weimer Republic,
they have access to the
state administration
as a result of violent political
antisemitism can be seen
when one notice that for the
first time in American history,
many Jews will were appointed
by Joe Biden in his cabinet
as secretary of treasury,
at the state department,
at the department of
justice, at the security,
or even at the CIA one
can guess unfortunately,
that a new wave of a
political antisemitism
will give some kind of legitimacy
to the Lacrimose theory
within the United States.
Thank you.
- Thank you Pierre for the
really interesting talk.
So we have about 20 minutes for questions
and I ask people to submit
questions in the Q and A.
I'll get us started,
and then we'll be happy to
ask the audience's questions.
So, first of all, it's
just interesting for us
to have a French person
view what's American history
and the, especially the history
of American antisemitism.
It's a fascinating perspective,
especially for me as
someone who an American
who works on France, but
I'm did first of all,
just in a somewhat personal question,
but what motivated you
to write this book now?
Why did you decide to write
about American antisemitism
in this moment today?
- I have no real answer in a way this book
is for following the previous one,
the one which was called
(speaking in a foreign language)
comparing between France
and United States,
but mainly on the legal
system on the Supreme court
and the (speaking in a
foreign language) in France.
And as you know, historians
are always influenced
by the kind of issues
they are facing themself
in their period of time living.
So obviously what was
occurring in the United States
maybe brought me to this issue
in which in fact, I was
working since many years.
In fact, since many years,
I've been working on Salo
Baron and Lacrimose theory.
This book, the contract for this book
was signed maybe 10
years ago, 12 years ago.
- So before-
- Galimar was kind enough to wait
because I couldn't find
any meaningful material
to discuss Salo Baron logic of history.
And I've been looking at different issues,
colonial history, many,
many different issues.
And certainly the United States case
was fitting quite nicely.
It gave me a kind of opportunity
to complete this book
and to face this extremely
strange, very meaningful,
very interesting controversy
launched by Salo Baron in 1928
which was, it was like a turn
like something so important,
such a shock with an American,
with all, for all Jewish historians,
something completely that
couldn't be understood.
So I really want to go
back to this controversy
for many years.
And suddenly, let's say during the 2000,
and I don't know, 15, 16,
I found the American case
something which could
be an interesting way
to deal with this Salo
Baron interrogation.
- Yeah, and I would just point out that.
Salo Baron's family has endowed
our research grants, the-
- I didn't know.
- Yeah, very nice.
So you lay out in your book
and in your talk a kind of
implicit comparison, I would say
between France and United States.
So you have the French model,
which is a strong state,
but a relatively weak
communal form of Jewish life.
But Jews are kind of at
the center of state power,
at least after a certain
point in the 19th century,
contrasted with the United
States with a weak state,
robust communal Jewish life,
but Jews are for the most
part removed political power
until relatively recently.
So my question is, which
model do you think is better
for the Jews in that sense?
- In my book, I quote a
very interesting sentence
by (indistinct) I don't
know if you noticed
this at the end of the book,
in which he said Jews
should never be the first
in the political system,
Jews should never appear
as a central figure.
Jews should remain at the local level.
It's a crucial question.
And as a lover of the
state, it's different.
It's difficult for me to say
that this is a worst solution
because it is true that the
closes they are to the state,
the stronger they are becoming a target,
the stronger antisemitism
let's look at Hitler himself.
You cannot understand Hitler
without Jews entering within the state.
During the Weimer Republic.
The crucial question for Hitler
was to destroy his oppression
state, this oppression state,
which had became a Jewish state.
So you see the relation, it's awful.
This kind of relation between the state,
which liberate the Jews, emancipates them
and the negative consequence against them.
On the other side,
when Jews are remaining
peacefully at the periphery,
nothing like that occurred
they remain at the periphery.
They are in a way outside history.
They have, they are living their suburbs,
a nice quite collective life,
but maybe something
nevertheless is missing
in their action, in their presence,
within their own society.
The far as they remain
outside the center of society
by many aspect they are like,
if they didn't really
belong to this society,
I don't know it's difficult.
- I mean, yeah, and you, it's-
- [Pierre] It's my main question.
- Yeah, and you trade,
it's very interesting
because at the end of your talk
and at the end of the book,
you show that, you know,
really since Roosevelt,
but especially under Biden now,
there're really, you know, we
have the kind of equivalent
of what you call the state Jews in France.
We have many Jews
that really the center
of the administration.
And so according to your theory,
I mean, it might, that
might be not so right.
- I hope my theory is wrong.
- Right, okay.
So here's a question from the audience
and it's something that you
talk a lot about in your book,
but didn't come up in the talk.
And I was wondering if you
could say a little bit more
about the role of anti-black
prejudice in the United States
and it's relationship to antisemitism.
This is something that
comes up a lot in your book
and how the whole problem of from slavery
on here affects the way that Jews are seen
or the relationship between
anti-black prejudice
and anti-Semitism.
- Well, it's quite obvious
that black Americans
are really the target of
prejudices in the United States,
not the Jews and black Americans
were killed so many of them
and still are killed so
many of them, not the Jews,
but there is another question is,
if they're kind of black
American antisemitism
killing the Jews.
And as I said, sometimes
it is too much outline.
There is a literature
in the black American,
black Panthers and so on,
which was quite antisemitic.
There is a black American literature,
which has some anticipated dimension.
I once met Malcolm X in Paris
and he was in a private unknown meeting
far from any control.
And he was really having
some very strange sentences
on this dimension.
But in fact, if you quantify,
if you look at the numbers,
there were very few Jews,
there who were some who were killed
by black American.
Very few in fact, most of them,
and I discussed this in the book.
Most of them, the large majority
were killed by white
extremist, white radical Nazi,
white Protestant Christian members,
members of Ku Klux Klan and so on.
So I dunno if I really answered.
- [Maurice] Yeah, I mean, I was kind of,
I thought you would maybe say something
as you do in your book about
how, in a sense, you know,
especially in the south,
in the American south,
but in the north too, the
kind of greater prejudice
against black people in a sense lessened,
maybe the prejudice against Jews.
I mean, it's sort of an obvious point.
- It's quite obvious.
- [Maurice] Yeah, but another
question that's a few, yeah.
- Let me add some short remark.
- Yeah.
- Which, what is really remarkable
is what occurred during
the Leo Frank Case.
Because Conley was there,
he was a black American,
they were as a black American.
And really it did look as
the one who did the murder.
He was there, discovered Mary Fagan.
He brought her body.
He really could have been the murderer.
There were a lot of arguments he wrote.
And he consciousness,
he said that he wrote these
very strange sentences,
which was found on the side
of Mary Fagan dead body.
He wrote it.
He said it cause there
was a lot of evidence
that he might have been the killer.
But the jury, and it was
a time in which lynching
of black American lynching occurred a lot.
So why is it that the jury and the people,
the notables wanted Leo Frank,
the Jew to be the killer.
This is a very intriguing Case.
I cannot really answer, but
this is quite interesting case,
which is against the main logic.
The Jew is a nice man and
black American are the bad one.
- Yeah, it's very, very interesting.
So here's a question that
several people have asked.
And I, it was a question I had too.
It seems from your talk,
but also I would say in the book
that you mainly identify the threat,
the anti-Semitic threat facing Jews
to be coming from the right
or from the Alt-right.
But what about what they
call the new anti-Semitism
or anti-Zionism, where does
that fit into your picture?
Do you not see that as great a threat
as the antisemitism from the right?
- I'm really sorry, but it doesn't fit.
My study doesn't fit at all.
Anti-Zionist, never kill any Jew.
I'm really sorry.
The members of the Extreme Left,
and they're not really
extreme in the United States,
never killed Jew in the United States.
They may right arguments against Israel.
They may be critical of Jewish ritual.
They may be hurting Jewish feelings
of Jewish student at the university.
They may be acting wrongly against them,
but they never kill anyone.
- Right, although the recent attack
on the synagogue in Texas,
I think was by someone
who came from the UK.
But I think that was an anti-Zionist.
He didn't kill anyone.
Thank God.
But I think, but I take your point.
- I don't know.
- I take your point.
So what about different
kinds of Jewish opposition
to antisemitism and you show in your book
that it was really Kishinev
that really created the first,
you know, the American Jewish-
- [Pierre] Committee.
- Committee.
You know, so could you
talk a little bit about
the role of Jewish
opposition to antisemitism
and whether you think, you know,
I would say in the past, but
also in our current moment,
and whether you think that, you know,
now that Jews do have
more power than they did
at the beginning of the 20th century,
do you think they should
be doing something else?
Something different.
- I confess that I have no idea.
I really don't know
how they will be able
to face what's coming.
I'm afraid that something
worse could come very easily.
If Biden would be losing the power
or if anything would happen,
I'm really scared about what could happen.
And it's quite painful
when you see that nowadays.
So many Jewish institutions,
in America are going to protect
themselves like in France,
building walls, big walls
not only built in Israel.
That they are being built
protecting Jewish institution
all over the French territory.
And there are nowadays being built
in many Jewish
institutions, United States.
It gave Jews a kind of
being potentially threatened
by some degree of violence.
They never faced before.
And I really don't know what could be done
to protect them in this society,
in which the state administration
is not really a strong,
organized, centralized state.
- Yeah.
- I'm worried.
- Okay, yeah.
So if you could talk a little
bit more about this concept,
which was key, I think,
to your talk about American exceptionalism
and is American exceptionalism,
does that concept only really refer
to the lack of antisemitism
in the United States?
Or do you think there are other forms
of American exceptionalism
in regard to Jews?
Are there other aspects
of American Jewish history
of that are exceptional
or is the whole concept of
American exceptionalism false?
And we should just do away with it.
- It might become false,
but during the 18th century,
mainly the 19th century,
it was not false at all.
Jews had a peaceful life
in a decentralized society
in which a state was not threatening them
in which no one was
threatening them in fact.
So I think that at the core of Jewish
of the American history is
the notion of pluralism,
which will become later
on multiculturalism,
from pluralism to
multiculturalism nowadays.
Iphiniated society, the
famous iphiniated society
from Horas Kalane to Michael Woza
give the Jew like to other minorities,
a strong legitimacy to live peacefully,
having many dimensions of
the, within their identities.
It is at the core of
American, exceptionalism,
the idea of iphiniated society, pluralism,
sharing many identities,
being both Irish and American,
Chinese, and American, unfortunately,
maybe not Japanese and American.
That is really at the core of
American exceptionalism boost.
The notion of pluralism, the
notion of decentralization,
and of iphiniated identity,
which allow Jews to be in
favor of Israel also openly,
without hiding, themselves in France,
it's becoming something
which can be stated openly,
but will it be some strong consequences?
In fact, as you know, as much
as I do in the 19th century,
French Israel elite were never Zionist.
Whether in the United States
look at Louis Brandis.
Louis Brandis was at the
top of the Supreme court
and he was leading at the same time,
the Zionist organization of America
and believable in France,
you couldn't be openly having
such an important function
in Zionism institution
and being at the same time
at the highest level
of the judicial system.
So there is a specificity.
- Okay, so maybe last question here,
if you could just say a few remarks about,
well, to compare the situation facing Jews
in France and America today.
So the antisemitism in France
versus the antisemitism
in America, if you could,
if you had any thoughts about the threats
that Jews face in the two countries,
are they similar or different threats?
- Well, as you know, in France,
they are facing both the
extreme right antisemitism,
which is extremely strong.
And unfortunately there
is a strong antisemitism
in some parts of the of
Muslim citizens in France.
So some of them are sharing.
France is closer to the Middle East.
France is a lot of immigrants
coming from the Middle East,
from Algeria society, which was,
which is still more or
less in war with Israel.
So there is kind of Middle
East, not I Iraq and not Iran,
but middle east, which
is much more present
at the core of the French society.
There's also a new aspect,
which is linked to this
Middle East question,
is the fact that Jews in France
are more and more
Israelization themselves.
They are, they've got a
lot of families in Israel
when someone is interviewing in Israel,
when there is something
happening in Israel,
the French journalist will
go there and ask someone,
what's happening and the guy
is going to answer in French.
You will find thousands of French Jews
speaking French in Israel.
So the French journalist
will ask them in French,
what's happening and the
guy will answer in French.
So there is a kind of confusion
between Israel and the French Jews.
There are more and more
involved within the French.
Within the Israeli history,
they eat Israeli food,
they sing Israeli songs, they
read French Israeli newspaper
or English Israeli newspaper.
They follow day by day,
what's happening there.
They dance with the
music coming from Israel,
which is not the case
in the United States.
As you know, American
Jews are to the contrary
going far more and more far
from the Israeli situation.
Most of them never went to Israel.
In France, most Jews went
several times in Israel.
There is the strong difference
between the two countries.
- Yeah, okay, well, that I
think brings us to the end.
I feel like we could
keep talking all night.
But that brings us to the
end of our session today.
But let's hope last question is,
what about the English
translation of this book?
Will it be translated into English?
- Maurice it's up to you,
to someone in the audience.
That will be really nice.
And I would be very sorry
if it's not translated.
- Yeah, so what guys, it's
such a fascinating book.
You're kind of updating Talk Ville
and making it, the, you know, as you say,
Talk Ville did, was not interested in Jews
and you're kind of adding that dimension.
So thank you.
- You Talk Ville and you
should take care of that.
- Okay, I'll translate
it in, on my spare time.
Okay, well, so thank you Pierre so much,
and I'm sorry, you can't hear everyone,
but I will clap for
everybody in the audience.
- Thanks a lot.
- And thank you all for coming.
I urge everybody to please sign up
for the YPSA, Y-P-S-A mailing list.
So you can find out about our other talks.
We have a bunch of other interesting talks
planned for this semester,
and I look forward to
seeing you all at them soon.
And thank you again to Pierre.